[Music]
back in september prosecutors dropped
all of the charges against a mississippi
man who had been tried
six times for a quadruple murder curtis
flowers spent more than 20 years in
prison
most of it on death row he was convicted
four
times but maintained his innocence 60
minutes correspondent sharon alfonsey
spoke with him and there's a knock at
the door
and i answered it and next thing you
know i was all up against the wall
being handcuffed and he explained to me
that
we just have a warrant for your arrest
back in mississippi i said for what
and he said four counts of capital
murder yeah i said me are you sure you
got the right guy
every time
[Music]
flowers had no criminal record and was
more likely to be on stage with a gospel
group
than in handcuffs there was no murder
weapon
no dna or fingerprints linking him to
the crime
but it took an all-white jury just an
hour to deliberate and convict him
at age 27 curtis flowers was sentenced
to death
and put in the mississippi state
penitentiary known as parchment prison
were you scared oh yes what's parchment
like
the worst thing you ever dreamed about
yeah like a nightmare
because you know you hear all kinds of
noise at night you know
their inmates who have just snapped some
who have lost it
they act up all night you were sitting
on death row
i imagine other death row inmates were
being executed
yes and that was a nerve wreck in itself
his conviction was appealed and
overturned
but there would be five more trials for
curtis flowers
for the same crime by the same
prosecutor
how can a person be tried for the same
crime
six times this case is unprecedented
in the history of the american legal
system
unprecedented and shocking you can see
more of sharon's interview with mr
flowers
this sunday on 60 minutes the supreme
court of course struck down his
conviction
and one of the two justices that
dissented was clarence thomas
the only black justice on the bench and
he said if the court's opinion today has
any redeeming quality
it's this that the state is perfectly
free to convict curtis flowers again
obviously they won't do that because the
charges were dropped but interesting
six times six times